Os voy a hacer una pregunta y no vale buscarlo
en Google. Imaginad que os tenéis que comprar
una casa ¿Dónde creéis que es más barata?
¿En Barcelona o en Miami? Por si necesitáis
alguna pista, os diré que las dos ciudades
tienen, más o menos la misma población cuando
contamos con el área metropolitana. Ambas
ciudades tienen playa y son muy turísticas.
Además, el sueldo medio de Miami es casi
el doble que el de Barcelona y la tasa de
desempleo es muchísimo más baja. Dicho esto,
muchos pensaréis que, por lógica, Barcelona
tiene que ser más barata que Miami ¿Verdad?
¡Pues os equivocáis! Las viviendas en
Barcelona son un 15% más caras que las de Miami.
Sí, amigos de VisualPolitik, comprar una
casa en España es una auténtica misión
imposible. Pero ya sé lo que estáis pensando
muchos… Las viviendas son caras en todas
partes ¿Verdad? ¡Pues tenéis razón! Los
precios de las casas están creciendo en casi
todos los países. Y esto es sorprendente
si tenemos en cuenta que la tendencia en el
resto de bienes es al contrario.
Os lo hemos contado mil veces aquí, en VisualPolitik,
la humanidad va a mejor. Prácticamente hemos
erradicado la desnutrición en el mundo. Nuestro
nivel de vida es mucho más alto que el de
nuestros abuelos y esto se debe, entre otras
cosas, a que los productos que consumimos
son más baratos.
Por ejemplo, hace sólo 30 años, mi padre
tendría que ahorrar el sueldo de un mes para
poder volar de Madrid a Berlín. Y mis abuelos
tenían que hacer auténticos equilibrios
financieros para comer todos los días. Cosas
tan comunes en nuestra dieta diaria como la
carne de pollo o de ternera estaban reservadas
para bodas y grandes eventos.
Por suerte, hoy en día eso es historia. Sin
embargo, la vivienda es el único elemento
que no sólo no es más accesible sino que
se está convirtiendo en algo prohibitivo
en muchas partes del mundo.
En este vídeo vamos a centrarnos en el ejemplo
de España porque es donde hemos encontrado
más información, pero muchas de las cosas
que vamos a repasar pueden aplicarse a casi
cualquier país. Porque la pregunta que hoy
nos hacemos es ¿Por qué es tan caro comprar
una casa? ¿Hay alguna forma de solucionar
este problema? Hoy vamos a responder a todas
estas preguntas, pero antes, vamos a ver un
poco de historia. Y, por cierto, quedaros
hasta el final del vídeo porque tengo una
sorpresa para vosotros.
LA LEY DEL SUELO
¿Qué es lo primero y lo más importante
que necesitamos para construir una casa? Efectivamente,
el suelo donde vamos a edificarla ¿Verdad?
Pues bien, en ese aspecto, España tiene la
geografía perfecta. Hablamos de un territorio
enorme, principalmente plano y con muchísimas
zonas despobladas. Otros países como, por
ejemplo, PAÍSES BAJOS, si que tienen un auténtico
problema de densidad de población. Sin embargo,
España tiene espacio de sobra para todos
sus habitantes. Ahora bien, tener un terreno
en propiedad no significa que podamos usarlo
para construir viviendas. Por ejemplo, en
el año 2011, el 40% del suelo de Madrid estaba
considerado como NO URBANIZABLE. Es decir,
que el ayuntamiento limita la edificación
en estos territorios. En otras ciudades como
Málaga, este porcentaje ascendía a más
del 70%.
Y os preguntaréis ¿Por qué hay tantísimos
terrenos donde no se puede construir? La respuesta
está en los servicios municipales. Veréis,
cuando construimos una zona residencial, necesitamos
poner alcantarillas, electricidad, nuevas
líneas de autobuses y, por supuesto, recogida
de basuras ¿Y quién se hace cargo de todos
estos costes? Los ayuntamientos, es decir,
todos los contribuyentes cuando pagamos nuestros
impuestos. Dicho de otra manera: si una empresa
constructora saca una promoción de viviendas
en las afueras de Madrid y no las consigue
vender, todos los madrileños tendrán que
hacerse cargo de los servicios urbanos de
una zona fantasma. Y por eso, los ayuntamientos
quieren controlar hasta el mínimo detalle
de donde y cómo se expande su municipio ¿Habéis
oído hablar alguna vez de los PLANES DE ORDENACIÓN
URBANA? Pues bien, estos planes son un mapa
que saca un ayuntamiento cada diez años donde
se especifica en qué zonas se puede construir.
Pero esperad un momento, porque si veis este
vídeo desde España, ya sé lo que estaréis
pensando! ¿No se supone que el suelo está
liberalizado? Efectivamente, en el año 1997,
el Gobierno de José María Aznar sacó una
ley que suponía, en teoría, la liberalización
del suelo. Esto significa que, prácticamente,
todo el suelo del país pasaba a ser urbanizable.
Es decir, apto para la construcción. De repente,
todas las ciudades españolas crecieron y
surgieron montones de zonas residenciales.
Este fue el comienzo de la burbuja inmobiliaria.
¡Pero, como decimos muchas veces en VisualPolitik…
el diablo está en los detalles! Veréis,
hemos dicho que los Planes de Ordenación
Urbana determinan las zonas donde se puede
edificar. Pero no se quedan ahí. También
fijan las condiciones en las que se puede
edificar. Vamos a imaginar que pedimos un
permiso al Ayuntamiento de Barcelona para
poder construir un bloque de pisos en una
parcela que tenemos. Pues bien, el ayuntamiento
nos va a decir que no hay problema pero que
sólo podemos construir 20 viviendas, o 15,
o 10… ¿Entendéis el problema? Por mucho
que se legalice un suelo, es decir, que se
permita la construcción, la oferta de viviendas
continúa estando muy restringida.
Y, por cierto, esto también explica muchos
de los casos de corrupción que tenemos en
España. La mayor parte de escándalos que
estamos descubriendo en los últimos años
vienen porque un constructor pagaba un soborno
al concejal de urbanismo para que, en lugar
de tener un permiso para construir 10 viviendas,
le dieran uno para construir el doble. En
otras palabras, que en el sector de la construcción
existe un incentivo perverso para invertir
en sobornos más que en otras como, por ejemplo,
esta…
ANCLADOS EN EL SIGLO XX
¿A que no adivináis cuál es el sector menos
productivo de la economía? ¡Exacto! ¡La
construcción! Hablamos de un mundo donde
lo raro es que los proyectos se terminen en
la fecha en la que se habían previsto ¡Y
esto no sólo ocurre en España! Para que
os hagáis una idea, las nuevas oficinas de
APPLE, en Silicon Valley, se terminaron 2
años más tarde de lo esperado y tuvieron
un sobre costo de 2000 millones de dólares
extra. Y lo mismo ocurre con casi todas las
viviendas que se construyen hoy en día.
“Según una encuestra de un studio de arquitectura
británico, el 60% de sus obras se terminaban
tarde”
Y os preguntaréis ¿Por qué las empresas
de construcción son tan poco serias? La respuesta
está en que apenas han innovado en las últimas
décadas. Por supuesto que las casas de hoy
en día son mucho más modernas, tienen mejores
sistemas de aislamiento y calefacción. Pero
el modo en el que se construyen continúa
siendo el mismo que hace 50 años.
Cualquier otro sector económico ha avanzado
mucho más. Por ejemplo, una fábrica de coches
de hace 60 años no se parece en nada a una
fábrica de coches de hoy en día. La mayor
parte de los puestos de trabajo que tenían
nuestros abuelos han sido sustituidos por
máquinas y robots programados por ordenador
¿El resultado? Un automóvil de hoy en día
tiene muchas más prestaciones y, además,
es más barato de producir que hace 60 años.
Gracias a eso, ahora casi todas las familias
se pueden permitir uno o incluso dos.
Sin embargo, si viéramos una obra en los
años 60… apenas notaríamos diferencias
con lo que se hace ahora. Los mismos albañiles
y las mismas grúas. Las empresas de construcción
apenas han invertido en innovación. Y esto
es comprensible si tenemos en cuenta que su
margen de beneficio es extremadamente bajo.
¡Habéis oído bien! Una promotora de viviendas
puede tener unas ganancias de entre el 2 o
el 5%. Por supuesto que, cuando hablamos de
millones de euros, un 2% es más que suficiente
para hacer rico al dueño de la empresa. Pero
a duras penas permite invertir en otras cosas
como investigación y desarrollo. Y
por si esto fuera poco, los incentivos para
sustituir trabajadores por máquinas son bastante
pocos. A diferencia de otros sectores económicos,
no es necesario tener ninguna formación para
trabajar en la construcción. Y esto se traduce
en una mayor concentración de mano de obra
poco cualificada.
Así que podemos ir haciendo un pequeño resumen:
la oferta de suelo está restringida, lo que
hace que los precios de las propiedades suban
como la espuma y, después, la construcción
de la vivienda en sí es un proceso largo,
caro e impredecible ¿Resultado? Las viviendas
en España tienen precios prohibitivos. Sin
embargo… ¡Casi el 80% de los españoles
es propietario de su propia vivienda! ¿Cómo
es esto posible? ¡Ahora mismo lo vamos a
ver!
¡DINERO PARA TODOS!
Hay un principio básico en economía: las
cosas valen lo que alguien esté dispuesto
a pagar. Por ejemplo, si un piso de 4 habitaciones
en un barrio normal de Madrid vale más de
300.000 euros es porque hay gente que lo puede
pagar.
Pero ¿Cómo es posible que haya tanta gente
capaz de pagar tantísimo dinero? ¿No se
supone que en España hay crisis? ¿No habíamos
dicho que el salario medio en España es de
menos de 2000 euros al mes?
Pues… mis queridos amigos de VisualPolitik,
la respuesta está en los bancos.
300.000 euros es una auténtica fortuna para
alguien que está cobrando un salario medio.
Pero… si todo ese dinero se paga en cómodos
plazos durante varios años… es un poco
más fácil ¿verdad? ¿Y de cuánto tiempo
creéis que estamos hablando? ¿10 años?
¿veinte años? Pues… lo cierto es que hablamos
de muuucho más…
Hipotecas a 40 años: un producto exclusivo
para jóvenes y con condiciones
¡Habéis oído bien! 40 años. En España
no es raro encontrarse a gente que tiene hipotecas
a 40 años. Y alguno dirá ¿Pero… tiene
algún sentido?
Es decir… imaginad que sois un banco y le
concedéis un préstamo a devolver en 40 años
a una pareja. En 4 décadas, pueden ocurrir
mil y una razones por las cuales no puedan
devolver el dinero. Entonces ¿Dónde está
el negocio? ¿Cómo es posible que un banco
se pueda arriesgar tantísimo al conceder
un préstamo?
La respuesta está en los Bancos Centrales…
El Banco Central Europeo continuará imprimiendo
millones de euros para impulsar la Eurozona
hasta 2019
Tal cual como lo oís… Europa tiene hoy
más masa monetaria que nunca. Sin embargo,
Europa tiene una inflación relativamente
baja. En otros vídeos de VisualPolitik os
hemos explicado que cuando los bancos centrales
imprimen billetes, todos los precios tienden
a subir. Sin embargo, en Europa pasa todo
lo contrario ¿Por qué? Pues porque todo
ese dinero recién impreso va, directamente,
a los bancos. Y los bancos lo utilizan ¿Para
qué? ¡Efectivamente! ¡Para dar préstamos!
Eso explica que con unos salarios relativamente
bajos, la mayoría de los españoles estén
dispuestos a pagar auténticas fortunas por
tener una casa en propiedad. Y lo que es peor,
que el precio pueda continuar subiendo hasta
el infinito. Siempre habrá alguien dispuesto
a conceder o a aceptar hipotecas a 40 años.
En otras palabras, que todos los factores
apuntan a que, a largo plazo, las viviendas
son cada vez más y más caras. Y eso explica
cosas como esta.
Lo habéis oído mil y una veces… “invertir
en ladrillo es una inversión segura”. Todos
sabemos que no es del todo cierto. Pero seguro
que todos conocemos a alguien que invierte
sus ahorros en comprar casas. Es decir, que
junto a la gente que necesita comprar un piso
para vivir, tenemos a aquellos que lo compran
para invertir. Dicho de otra forma: los bancos
centrales inflan la demanda y los ayuntamientos
restringen la oferta ¿Conclusión? Las casas
son cada día más caras.
Y, por cierto, tengo que hacer un paréntesis
para dar las gracias al ESTUDIO DE ARQUITECTURA
DE MIGUEL ÁNGEL FONSECA por haberme ayudado
a entender todos los detalles del mundo de
la construcción y el urbanismo. Miguel Ángel
Fonseca es uno de los mayores expertos de
arquitectura sostenible de España y le podéis
escuchar todos los jueves en el programa Hoy
por Hoy, en la Cadena SER Valladolid. Os dejo
más detalles en la descripción del vídeo.
Así que ahora llega la pregunta de este vídeo
¿Cómo creéis que se solucionaría este
problema? ¿Habría que restringir las hipotecas
de los bancos? ¿Tendríamos que liberar el
suelo para que se pudiera construir? ¿Qué
tipo de políticas solucionarían este problema?
Podéis dejarme vuestra respuesta en los comentarios.
¡Y antes de que os vayáis, esperad un momento
porque tengo algo MUY importante que contaros!
Este 17 de febrero voy a dar una charla en
el evento TEDx la Malagueta, en Málaga. Voy
a contaros una historia que os va a encantar
sobre lobbies, supervivencia política y muchas
otras cosas. Los que viváis en Málaga y
alrededores tenéis una oportunidad fantástica
para venir a verme a mi a otros ponentes.
Y, como os podéis imaginar, para los suscriptores
de VisualPolitik tenemos un descuento MUY
especial del 20%. Sólo tenéis que comprar
vuestra entrada en la web TEDXMALAGUETA.COM
e introducir la palabra “VISUALPOLITIK”
en el código de descuento y… ¡Boom! Os
ahorráis el 20%. De verdad que es un evento
que va a merecer la pena y tengo muchas ganas
de veros a todos en persona. Así que ya sabéis,
el 17 de febrero nos vemos en Málaga en el
evento TEDx La Malagueta.
Y, como siempre, no olvidéis suscribíos
al canal si no lo habéis hecho ya para no
perderos ninguna de nuestras actualizaciones.
SI os ha gustado este vídeo, dadle a LIKE
y nos vemos en el próximo. Un abrazo y hasta
pronto!